To create a PowerPoint from the
newly linked Documents program, you only need
this essential information to see
how your AI works.
This is the PowerPoint presentation that my AI created
for me.  It's quite simple and just
lists the simplest directories
related to my .w file.  Hello everyone
.  Today I'm doing another series about AI for
office work.  In the previous episode, I
used Ivan's skill to create a
basic Excel skill for my AI.
Today I'll be using another skill of Ivan's
to work with PowerPoint.  This skill of his is
also being downloaded and used by over 40,000 people
.  If you have any
good ideas, please comment below.  If you
enjoyed this video, please like, share, and subscribe to give me
more motivation to make more videos
.  This is Avan's skill and has been
downloaded by over 40,000 people.  Now,
I've used my clock code
to summarize what skills Avan can
perform.
This is the code I used to
summarize this PowerPoint skill of yours.
The purpose of this skill is to create, test, and
edit PowerPoint presentations,
focusing on layout templates, placeholders,
notes, and charts to control
image quality.  There are six main rules:
choose workflow before editing, inventory
decks before changing content,
match content and the actual player,
preserve the visual language of Dex, and run QA
on content and images separately so that
decks are easily shareable and reviewable.
You should point out some common errors such as
placeholders and charts. Templates survive
if clearly visible; direct editing fails
if there are layout issues; then fans
replace them; and notes, comments, sharing links, and
aspect ratios to match.
These are basically his rules and guidelines
for PowerPoint.  And to copy, you just
need to go to his page and copy what I
've already copied—this skill of his—to
your computer. Just copy it all the way to the
placeholder. You can ignore
related skills and feedback.  After
copying it to the placeholder, I copied
my skill file to PowerPoint.  I
just copied everything over there.
After that, I'll
open my Antiravity program and,
first, like with Word and
Excel, I'll ask if it's
possible to transform my PowerPoint skill
into the main skill of the AI, and if it can be called
from this folder.  Then I
'll go into AI and do it that way.  These are the things
I want AI to do.  You can check the
PowerPoint
MD skill as a skill in AI that
can read this folder, and every time
I edit a
PowerPoint file, I use this skill.
I let Jamin run it, and
it finished running and updated
some rules. I'll read through them to see
how the rules have been updated.  Oh, and
it even includes a PowerPoint presentation for review
.  Excel Office suite includes programs like Doc, Excel, and
PowerPoint.  And every time it runs
PowerPoint, it has to read
this PowerPoint file first.  To read Aven's skills
first, refer to the PowerPoint.md skill file.
There.   Okay
.  Whichever demo the LED shows,
I will create a PowerPoint presentation from
this document.
Now I'm going to tell you, yes, I can use my AI to
create a PowerPoint presentation from this document.
Here, I'll share how to create
a PowerPoint presentation using the
new Docs document program.  We just need the
key information and then we'll see
how well our AI can handle it.
My AI phone has finished creating a
PowerPoint for me, called the
PowerPoint summary link program, so I can open it and
see what the PowerPoint looks like.
Worddog is a summary of the linking program.
This is the PowerPoint presentation that my AI created
for me.  It's quite simple and just
lists the
most basic folders for your w file, and
PowerPoint doesn't have any templates.
I always have POM setup skills in the description below
.  If you have any good ideas, please
comment below.  Please like, share, and
subscribe to give me more motivation to make
more videos.